laughs
[Music]
swampy Forest clearings like this one
are found throughout the Congo basin
in the local language they are known as
buys
free from the shade of the canopy
smaller plants flourish
[Music]
creating vital pit stops for grazing
animals
but by
are more than more than just Forest
clearings
they are places where salt and other
minerals
are hidden in the ground
many elephants
are nervous being out in the open due to
poaching
only under the cover of Darkness
does this bull step out of the Shadows
and into the by
filmed here for the first time
using only Moonlight
he knows exactly where to go
the salt and minerals he needs
are buried in the riverbed
and he has the perfect multi-tool
to mine for them
blowing Jets of air
he breaks up the sediments
creating a rich salty soup
[Music]
his trunk
as a jackhammer
cup
and straw
he barely spills a drop
the sound of the bull mining is a beacon
signaling to the more cautious Forest
residents that tonight
this by is safe
[Music]